- So a young woman allegedly
put Gorilla Glue in her hair
and may sue the manufacturer.
- When I do my hair, I like to, you know,
finish it off with a
little Got2b Glued spray.
Well, I didn't have any
more Got2b Glued spray,
so I used this.
- Does she have a claim?
Well, in America you can sue anyone
for anything at any time.
So you can file a lawsuit, it
doesn't mean that you'll win.
But, in terms of product liability,
it all comes down to the warning.
Number one, you don't have
a duty to warn about things
that aren't reasonably foreseeable.
Was it reasonably foreseeable that someone
would put this glue in their hair?
Maybe, maybe not.
Probably not.
Number two, if you get over that hurdle,
then you have to test the
sufficiency of the warning.
Was the warning that was given sufficient?
And, here, the Gorilla
Glue said specifically
don't bring it in contact with
skin and other body parts.
That's probably going to be sufficient.
But, again, you can file a suit,
it doesn't mean you're going to win.
But, come on, you already knew that.
And here's some more advice:
subscribe or I will see you in court.